alors mettez vous la mettez vous la
savez trés simple salle est très simple
ça s'appelle les chroniqueurs volant
parce que vous voyez vous avez chacun un
frisbee à votre effigie donc mettez vous
devant votre frisbee vous devrez lancer
votre frisbee et volé jusque dans le
four à micro ondes
alors évidemment si éventuellement vous
n'y arrivez pas si on peut couper les
retours parce que là c'est une horreur
alors si vous n'y arrivez pas c'est pas
dramatique on verra où vous êtes passé
c'est comme du curling est d'accord
alors je voudrais vous dire quand même
quelque chose on prépare une émission on
a découvert quelque chose de très
étonnant c'est que quelqu'un va être
avantagé ce soir parce que je l'ignoré
on a une championne de frisbee dans
l'équipe au d'après vous c'est qui la
vie pour le faire non je manque à 10 ans
daniel j'ai appris ça vous est
championne de frisbee non mais non mais
totalement par hasard face et se fait
vieux maintenant mais à royan en fait et
des championnats de frisbee freestyle à
ça s'appelle donc tu es un peu
acrobatique mais j'étais jeune à mes
jeux les plus touchés depuis longtemps
mais enfin je suis arrivé troisième
parce que chaque année des années est
valable c'est un peu le prolongement
maintenant normalement elle aime être
avantagés par rapport à mai alors je
fais des démonstrations ça doit donner à
peu près ça hein
si isabelle hallé je suis ils sont ma
voix on part de là alors ils ont l'an
passé la visite
[Applaudissements]
comme elle voit que dalle jean michel
venait pas je pense que les japonais
jada née il ya quand même des flèches en
france justin
en fait je vous rappelle quand même une
chose très importante c'est que ces
qualificatifs pour l'épreuve suivante
mais j'peux des conseils mais je peux
leur donner un conseil en fait il faut
bien calculé l'effet gyroscopique c'est
à dire voyez le lathan tu parlais même
l'animatrice aux sceptiques c'est pas
mal ah oui justin donc l'axé seine
exactement je vous rappelle qu'avec le
rebond qu'on a pensé qu'ils avaient qui
est devant lui
faites les tristes gilles ah oui j'ai le
même niveau jean-luc après ça sera
bernard de marocains qui arrive niveau
tu a relevé mais j'ai dit de prime time
la semaine prochaine bah justement on va
faire quelque chose de particulier pour
une autre bernard a les yeux en
attendant les nerfs et m'agresser en
plus haut lieu à mathieu si vous rentrez
dans le faux vous avez un prime time en
est il va la mettre donne un effet je
sais pas j'ai jamais joué à saleilles
vas-y tu vas faire un four est ce que
vous voulez voir une professionnelle à
l'oeuvre d'alain moreau on peut ce
mariage fait attention mais prête pas
attention on appelle des trucs c'est à
toi ben non ça va partir
[Musique]
[Rires]
battez-vous salalah
[Applaudissements]
et personne n'a rien vu dans les
guignols exactement 904 non c'est vous
fera rire là n'ont pas dépassé monétaire
plus qu'elle ne fera pas l'épreuve
suivante alors qui sait pas participé à
l'épreuve suivante
écoutez y en a 3 et 4 qui sont encore là
bernard vous étirer oui oui oui et bien
qu'est ce que vous foutez avec le
frisbee dans la main pour bernard est
éliminé jean-michel justine et le
dernier ses voeux de mathieu macho qui
seront les épreuves